The code you see below is a Python implementation of
a mapper for our word count problem. Imagine we have
a huge document filled with many lines of words. We
can send different chunks of the document to a number of
different mappers to get the job done. What's this mapper
code doing? Let's take a closer look. The mapper takes in
a document. For each line of the document, it creates
and array consisting of the words in that line of text.
We then cycle through the words. We clean each
word up so we remove any punctuation and make
all the letters lower case. Then for each word
we emit a key value pair. The word itself and
the number one. Note that the key value pair
is separated by a tab. So, if a particular
word appears multiple times in the document, we will
emit multiple identical intermediate key value pairs. The word and
the number one. Over and over again. Let's
say we ran this map around the following sentence.
Hello, My name is Dave. Dave is my name. The mapper would split the words on the
white space like so. The mapper would then
emit the following key value pairs. Hello one, my
one, name one, and so on. The next step
in the map reduced design paradigm, is to shuffle
the results produced by the mappers and send
all of the key value pairs corresponding to certain
keys to certain reducers. So, if we ran the
job with just one reducer, that reducer would process
all the keys. But, if we ran the job
with two reducers, one reducer might process half the
keys while the other reducer process the other half.
So, let's go back to our word count example.